et voilà c'est le curé rêve en direction
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des noms
dont j'ai parlé direction venir à côté
de moi je
n'imagine
pas la gueule c'est qu'ils connaissent
pas un mot
trouver
[Rires]
des mecs mais alors là les mecs là vous
avez tous fermez vos gueules quoi
je veux des excuses sympa
mais la forme est là à part delphine ya
des
personnes chargées d'une enquête
est enquêtrice personnes chargées
d'effectuer des sondages des sondages et
des enquêtes sanaa
l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
mais trois de choula
abonnés dans celui-là point de vue là tu
prends celui-là tuheiava
enquêteurs enquêteuse personne chargée
d'une enquête voilà c'est tout ouais tu
t'excuses s'excuser de quoi j'ai dit les
deux camps s'accusent
tu t'excuses tu serais à cette menace
oui
est-ce que la
poutre alors excuse toi à j'aimerais
avoir des lettres de xto
[Applaudissements]
voilà
et là tu t'excuses mais je m'explique
chef web merci madame merci notre
capacité la meilleure note encore jamais
benjamin ici et que ce soit avec ses
soirées tout vu il est beau prie de
m'excuser chez les anglais
sinon de souder la
radine père a dit alors c'est pas les
anglais mais je m'excuse pour le reste
j'ai des anglais
voilà c'est les anglais merci encore une
leçon de français dans cette édition
commence vraiment à faire beaucoup je
peux pas être partout
chantal tu es content tu as bien joué et
moi alors c'est que je regardais jamais
une émission de tête je vais regarder
pourquoi ouais je rigole pas
voilà
aux bien pensants talent non non non non
non non tu as été mauvaises langues
c'est pas la première fois
de leur vie je te le dis de la moe de la
vie